[Music]
you
the city has just opened its
one-of-a-kind Faberge egg museum with a
single egg displayed on each floor of a
100 storey building and the world's most
notorious jewel thief already has her
eyes on the prize
because security is tight and the eggs
are so large she'll only get the chance
to steal one by dropping it out the
window into her waiting truck and
rappelling down before the police can
arrive all eggs are identical in weight
and construction but each floors egg is
more rare and valuable than the one
below it while the thief would naturally
like to take the priceless egg at the
top she suspects it won't survive a 100
storey drop being pragmatic she decides
to settle for the most expensive eggs
she can get in the museum's gift shop
she finds two souvenir eggs perfect
replicas that are perfectly worthless
the plan is to test drop them to find
the highest floor at which an egg will
survive the fall without breaking of
course the experiment can only be
repeated until both replica eggs are
smashed and throwing souvenirs out the
window too many times is probably going
to draw the guards attention what's the
least number of tries it would take to
guarantee that she finds the right floor
if you're having trouble getting started
on the solution it might help to start
with a simpler scenario imagine our
thief only had one replica egg she'd
have a single option to start by
dropping it from the first floor and go
up one by one until it breaks then she'd
know that the floor below that is the
one she needs to target for the real
heist but this could require as many as
100 tries having an additional replica
egg gives the thief a better option she
can drop the first egg from different
floors at larger intervals in order to
narrow down the range where the critical
floor can be found and once the first
breaks she can use the second egg to
explore that interval floor by floor
large floor intervals don't work great
in the worst case scenario they require
many tests with the second egg smaller
intervals work much better for example
if she starts by dropping the first egg
from every 10th floor once it breaks
she'll only have to test the nine floors
below that means it'll take at most 19
tries to find the right floor
and she do even better after all there's
no reason every interval has to be the
same size let's say there were only 10
floors the thief could test this whole
building with just four total throws by
dropping the first egg at floors 4 7 & 9
if it broke at floor 4 it would take up
to three throws of the second egg to
find the exact floor if it broke at 7 it
would take up to two throws with the
second egg and if it broke at floor 9 it
would take just one more throw of the
second egg intuitively what we're trying
to do here is divide the building into
sections where no matter which floor is
correct
it takes up to the same number of throws
to find it we want each interval to be
one floor smaller than the last this
equation can help us solve for the first
floor we need to start with in the 100
floor building
there are several ways to solve this
equation including trial and error if we
plug in 2 for n that equation would look
like this if we plug in 3 we get this so
we can find the first n to pass 100 by
adding more terms until we get to our
answer which is 14 and so our thief
starts on the fourteenth floor moving up
to the 27th the 39th and so on for a
maximum of 14 drops like the old saying
goes you can't pull a heist without
breaking a few eggs did you enjoy this
lesson if so please consider supporting
our nonprofit mission by visiting
patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]